and spencer howard his second major
league start yeah he really has a very
impressive arsenal there's no question
about it so now dom smith who's playing
left field tonight infield back at
double play depth they'll try and turn
two to concede a run
and that's hit down to second grab by
segura out at second and
relay is dropped
and a run comes home
gregorius unable to make the transfer
effectively would have an easy chance at
a double play so two outs of run in
robinson cannot swing it a miss side is
retired first strikeout of the night for
spencer howard as far as the pitching
while it won't be provided by jacob
degrom for the minutes as originally
scheduled instead it'll be walker locket
because degrom had come up with a stiff
neck he wanted to go but you know
they're trying to be as careful as
possible so lock it in immediate
difficulty a single and a hit by pitch
and that'll bring up the red hot bryce
harper
back to lock and a chance for two
rosario with the turn and they get the
double play
here's luis guillermo and they've got a
runner third with less than two out for
the second straight inning
and he hits this one a deep right center
should be deep enough but harper got
misjudged and he fell falls in front of
him and in the score comes jimenez and
the mets have a two to nothing lead
runners at first and second with one out
and here's alec bone
there's a line drive basing it to center
field dede's around third heading for
home and he's going to score it's an rbi
single for alec balm
it's his first big league rbi it's a 2-1
ball game roman quinn the hitter with
rudders on first and third in a run in
line drive makes it to left field
that'll bring home segora the game's
tied at two and that is a great sign to
see roman quinn go the other way
you go to the third inning the mets two
the phillies too dominic smith had an
rbi his first time
tom gets under one to right field back
goes harper onto the warning track right
at the wall he can't get it it's a home
run dom smith clears the fence his third
straight game with a home run is fifth
of the year and the mets go back in
front three to two robinson canoe struck
out in his first at bat off the injured
list
deep right field forget that robinson
canoe parks one way up there back to
back home runs for smith and canelo
robbie hits his second of the year and
the mets laid four to two
this isn't good no joe girardi is
heading to the mounds
with sean faczny the phillies athletic
trainer to look at spencer howard
blister yeah middle finger nope that is
it
he's getting his rosin bag and brian
signals to the pen
first and second now one out for j.t
romuta
in the air to left field dominic smith's
going back and get it as young
it's a three-run home run and jt has
just given the fills
a 5-4 lead clutch cargo he gets a fast
ball and he gets it up and he does not
miss it
that's off the board here in the sixth
runner at second the pitch to brandon
nimbo fly ball left field bruce
sprinting in bone sprinting out and bow
makes the over the shoulder grab what a
play
tremendous concentration by alec balm
that is a tough play for so many
different reasons one he's running away
from the play
two he almost has to make a circus catch
and he's got bruce bearing down on him
so alonso is over three today he's got
guillermo at second conforto at first
with two down and pete sky's one deep
left center back in the gap goes quinn
back near the wall to make the catch
he'd hit it a long way but not long
enough
broke his back diving stop reese on one
hop the flip to first in time just a
heck of a play you know rhys has really
played well defensively this year he's
trimmer he's he looks like he's in great
shape
and he's made a couple of great plays
we've seen some of the picks he's done
but
that's a big league play right there
luis guillaume is on board for the
fourth time tonight billy hamilton will
pinch run
he's going pitch is taken for a strike
to throw to second on one hop not in
time it gets away from segora hamilton's
going to third the throw he is out of
third base
that's really confident that you are
faster than everybody else including
faster than that baseball that's that's
the one thing i guess he did not see
dede getting over there
so neres with back-to-back strikeouts of
alonso and smith and thus the mets are
down to their final line of the night
and it's up to robinson canoe
and it's hit on the ground toward the
whole base hit here comes nimmo around
third harper up with the ball his throw
to the plate is not in time and the game
is tied all the way to third goes
conforto it's five to five robbie cadeau
comes through
one out bottom of the ninth 5-5 game
runners at first and second for the
fills and it'll bring up bryce harper
and a line drive out to right field
that'll drop in for a hit roman quinn's
being waved home conforto's throw to the
plate in the air he is saved he got his
hand in the phillies win the ball game
they're gonna review it get that hand in
he did
what he sure did look to the right
yes
and the phillies have won the ball game
and finally
the celebration
it ain't the same no matter how you look
at it
but it certainly is
a beautiful victory for the fills they
win it six to five
of the rbi walk-off single by bryce
harper